okay
stars ready yes kneel ready okay let's
go first order six covers table 15 six
pasta yes
six tackle telly six venison six
puddings
chef let's go russell move your ass yes
yes
this is not blackpool pier now big boy
let's go yes yes chef after six
four more come on and why is the water
not boiling
just added it turn up the heat yep put
some tinfoil on top
yeah bring it to the ball rapidly yes
let's go i started tonight is a very
very delicious tacotelli of wild
mushrooms and wild mushrooms this time
of year is absolutely perfect because it
really is now
mushroom season service please
now what's the secret behind cooking
mushrooms cook the thicker ones first
and the thinner ones later so that the
ones i have too much water
more importantly let me just show you
grab a handful of mushrooms
okay just a few of each mushroom watch
the water that comes out
yeah it's just water we're using a
mixture of wild mushrooms including
shiitake
chirol and trumpet de mor the reason
wild mushrooms are great
is they have a much more intense flavor
okay good hot pan
i sauteed the mushrooms with shallots in
a very hot pan to get a really good
flavor
i start off with oil because butter
burns too easily once the mushrooms
start to cook
a knob of butter finishes off the flavor
beautifully
my brigade this week angie great to have
her back in the kitchen especially being
a woman
this week angie's joined by neil are we
scott in the corner
but a big talent and of course i've got
my right hand man
mark sargent my two comments this week
are stosie from lancashire and russell
from blackpool on order four covers
table twelve four tagliatelle wild
mushrooms four venison
four rhubarb crumble wait wait no answer
stozie
you're weak yes chef yeah come on i want
to hear you please
let's go now stosie pressure's on now
yes heat's turned up
let's see if we can cut it turn that
water down because the pasta is going
over cooking literally seconds yeah
yes yes how long stosie uh one minute
make this one the best one sweetheart
yes otherwise you're taking an early
shower
yeah chef russell and stosie are just
two of over 1 000 people applied to work
in the f-word kitchen
i put the best 100 through a weekend of
tests and challenges
to find the 12 who would make it to the
restaurant
that looks like it's just come out of a
dishwasher each week
two trainees compete head-to-head for a
chance to win a job in one of my
kitchens
stop what you're doing everybody hello
stop what you're doing each week
someone has to go home you're going home
and you'll stay thank you you are
staying
clear clear down yes sweep the floor but
try to do it
with some cling film over your mouth
yeah good and thank you
i love you today tonight in the kitchen
it's stosie i think it tastes quite nice
she's a chef of 14 years who's never
worked as part of a team
i love seeing customers or people that
eat my food
who seem to think it did the right thing
it hit the right spot
and joining her is russell a catering
student from blackpool whose parents
run a chinese takeaway
that is actually very delicious i
definitely got a lot to learn
and that's the whole reason why i've
come to this competition is because i
want to learn from the best people
have you chased it yes chef yeah and i
think it's okay chef
pasta's overcooked stop it again face it
if you don't know that now you should be
in the kitchen you know that chef
pasta's like
glue it's not even it's got no bite to
it
it's lost it's it's greasy it's it's
good
start again take the mushrooms out four
more tegla telly come on russell please
the pasta goes in at the last minute
even from the heat or the mushrooms
helps to cook the pasta even more
so it should be dipped in there your
hand should lead the basket
in out into the mushroom yes
i know not everyone has time but pasta
dough is really easy to make
just combine flour eggs and olive oil in
a food processor
remove and knead for about two to three
minutes until the dough is smooth and
elastic
wrap in climb film and chill for at
least half an hour
the secret behind making good pasta is
not allowing it to dry out so you have
to really move your ass
right sir stosie and russell let's go
first thing we have is a nice flower
table roll the pasta
just to take a little bit of the sort of
weight off the pasta machine so we just
get it a little bit thin
so it starts to go through the machine
okay and let the machine do the work
every time it goes through the machine
it goes down a number
yeah now to cut it fold it nice and
neatly
but while we fold it we just sprinkle it
with flour
here we go up and round and then from
there
nice long length pasta look at where we
are you don't really want any longer
than that because you've got to think of
the customers
pulling it from their bowl so let's go
there shall we okay
yeah take a telly one piece through back
of the hand
in the machine yes up and look
here it comes it's almost like going to
the hairdresser isn't it that nice
fringe
let those little bits dangle off and
then dry
on to there yes there we go let's go
nice very nice the most important thing
about the presentation with the
takatella mushrooms is get your
tongue and twist the tagliatelle round
so it almost shapes a really nice ball
in the center of the plate then
get your wonderful sauteed mushrooms
oozing of garlic and shallots and just
let them sort of
fall on top of the tagliatelle but the
secret is to make sure the technicality
is not all broken up just like that
nice and relaxed palms and cheese on
there quickly
let's go stosie up move over that's it
no there you go gotta be on your toes in
the kid you know that yeah
yeah you're heavy-footed like a little
baby elephant running around clump clump
clump clump
go table two please go go
go go go four take to tell you how long
after that four more tagliatelle away
please
hello hello how was the technically wild
mushrooms
it's very nice a little bit more
seasoning
i thought it tasted amazing the pasta
and the mushrooms the garlic
the herbs unbelievable oh so many tastes
in one go
unbelievable very nice i wouldn't
attempt it myself but it was it was very
good
nothing was overpowering but you could
taste every individual ingredient it was
really beautiful
[Music]
next on the menu along with our main
course of venison with chocolate sauce
i poisoned my best friend the campaign
continues to get women back in the
kitchen
wait tell the neighbours the kitchen's
been used
[Applause]
and more fun down on my farm
no more
[Applause]
we're going to start cooking now guys
yes cleaning out that pan
yes welcome back to the f-word the food
show that's good enough to eat
next up is the roasted venison on a bed
of creamy cabbage with a red wine sauce
finished with bitter chocolate okay
stones you with
you understand what's going on yes check
yeah yeah you've got four in plus six is
ten
now i want five one of those five is for
the food critic good girl let's go
get rid of the fat in there please yeah
yeah let's go in the oven
venison's not just for posh people like
giles you can buy it in supermarkets so
go on try it at home
[Applause]
a lot of people get a little bit worried
about venison because they think it's
sort of very gamey and very strong but
it's not
salt pepper hot pan
olive oil
[Music]
seal
[Applause]
butter base
butter paper it protects the venison
keeps it
really nice and moist nothing's drying
out
they are the perfect chef's blanket
hotter than eight minutes
red wine chocolate sauce
pancetta shallot garlic
they're quite generous to the black
peppercorns because we need to wait the
sauce off a it
thyme bay leaf
350 meals red wine
the red wine gives it body texture and a
real nice
depth of flavor reduce
[Music]
350 ml brown chicken stock
[Music]
reduce
sieve then a little
dash of raspberry vinegar dark chocolate
delicious sauce
don't slice it too thin
slightly pink in the center
loin of venison with red wine chocolate
sauce
done the combination of chocolate and
red wine may sound a little bit weird
but they
really do go well together and it's very
rich so you don't need
a lot of it when grating the chocolate
into the sauce whisk it in gently but be
sure
not to boil the sauce otherwise there's
a possibility it will curdle
if it does start to curdle then change
pans quickly
into a cold pan to bring the sauce back
together
okay with the venison we're going to
serve a cream cabbage yes yes okay so
it's cabbage with celeriac
carrots yeah and pancetta and the
celeriac gives it a little bit of sort
of
it makes it sort of tastes almost like
the garden you know it's a root
vegetable
it's grown underneath it doesn't see any
sort of daylight so it's all
underground so the flavor is
extraordinary okay
the vegetables and pancetta need brisk
frying for four to five minutes before
adding the cream
and we go around the outside of the pan
okay all the way around so by time it
hits the center
yeah it's all nice and thick that is the
dish on its own let alone the venison
to go on top into your bowl
creamy winter cabbage with schlerak okay
good
okay angie six bennett on here stosie
six on there please yes after that you
followed by four
yes sauce please that's nicely cooked
there ange
nice and pink sauce please come on
russell automatic now
come on think about it come on
go please that six you just sent there
were the best come on let's go
yes
did you enjoy your starter it wasn't bad
it wasn't bad it was like it was lovely
cold plates though there someone's got
to be fired in there if it cooled down a
little bit i like it piping hot would
have been nice over here
so how's the campaign going to get women
in the kitchen campaign's going
fantastically well
to the extent that 2 000 women apply for
my help but there was one woman
who stood out from the rest she didn't
even know where the kitchen was
[Music]
kieran's a professional rugby player so
his diet is really important to
how he plays and how he trains and i
don't really
help him in that area at all nice to
meet you
one thing i hate the most that's him
having won over on me
so and the cooking thing is the only
thing he's got on me at the moment so if
i can match him in that area we're going
to be pretty equal
now you look immaculate manicured and
sort of almost like you've never broken
sweat
you're probably right the fingers are
soft nails are just immaculate
yeah yeah tell me why can't you cook
everything seems to go wrong for me when
i cook i either undercook
things overcook things get all the
timings wrong just
nothing ever seems to work out for me in
the kitchen she's cooking one or two
meals
i'm worth disaster uh worst disaster
putting one of her friends in hospital
i poisoned my best friend you poisoned
your mate
i did by giving her uncooked chicken and
she spent two days in hospital
oh my goodness me so today we've got all
the rugby players coming around for
lunch
i'm trying to think of something that is
simple yep
sophisticated and something that can
sort of serve
a large table okay and something that
can help get your confidence
going in the right direction and it is
just a good old fashioned
fish pie oh my god i've never ever
touched raw fish there you go nice
handle full of prawns what do i feel
like
god dear dear see what i'm trying to do
is get you dirty
dirty enough right there you go all you
need to do
is just take the salmon cut it in half
watch your fingers there right into nice
big long lines
and then from there and that's the dice
i i hate it if kieran's like better at
something than i am
so that's quite healthy that the fact
that it's competitive you know
definitely he would be so surprised if
he came home from training and there was
a stunning meal sitting on the table
that's fish stock
right really good healthy fish stock
what does that need in there salt yeah
good
let's put half foot in there okay give
it a little stir
now we don't want to stir it too much
what happens we stir it rapidly what
happens to the fish
the fish is just going to break up break
and crumble
flip an egg you've just started to sweat
hold it down and toss that's it there
good good
so now we've got two things going on at
once great yeah you're starting off the
mushrooms you're cooking off your fish
yep flip what's that smoke alarm has
ever gone off before
no flipping there's hallelujah
wait tell the neighbors the kitchen's
been used
the kitchen's been used okay great
good try and get the salmon yeah
throughout the dish so it's really nice
and
look there's nothing worse than having a
pie
that's missing filling the nice thing
about this we don't need to season it
why don't we
season it because we've seasoned it
throughout exactly
okay the smell of that yeah we haven't
even finished cooking it yet
smells great a nice tip when you're not
too sure is just
dust your top yeah put that down
there's your mark yeah it's almost like
creating a little football pitch look
there you go now you know what size to
roll to and if you want the width
one there one there there you go that's
where you got to stick with it
a bit further up because you'll be
shortened there right there good
look at the color those fingernails oh
what happened there's flour there's salt
there's salmon there's monkfish there's
cod there's
peas there's onions there's parsley
there's stuck in there
okay lights on and hopefully
they're gonna rise just turn that up a
little bit
they're here when was the last time you
had ten big dudes like that set at the
table
i've never had that many people sit
around my table be careful not to
destroy the pastry
okay leave that one in there cooling
down okay
stacy's fish pie
[Music]
this one's for you dors doing happy very
happy
stays happy i'm really happy do you
remember we said about the competitive
streak earlier
yes i think i've matched him highly
competitive
uh cheers um wasps i mean sorry
hi guys good to see you
have you done anything i have you have
changed my life
oh no oh babe
what have you cooked i've cooked a roast
dinner seriously
chicken pie chicken pie as well as a
roast lunch karen's pretty tough to be
honest
yeah good old yeah brilliant it's
brilliant
you know i think that cooking's not just
a high school tour it's kind of like she
enjoys it so
happy all right guys it's really
important okay that hopefully
you'll get back to your kitchen you go
back to your kitchen and you'll go back
to yours
and do some cooking surely i was hoping
you'd go and see we'll hear
my girl and uh give her a few lessons as
well you want me to go around and see
your lady and help a girl
cooking i think you should do some
cooking
yes you know i'm really pleased the fact
that you've got the conference back
you're cooking
and you feel really comfortable with it
that's so important i'm just more
confident in the kitchen that's correct
now when's the next england match coming
up
not the first game against australia i
think it is so it's uh exciting times
again
so we stuck them with a cricket please
give it to them from behind again for
the rugby yes and then after a
successful match
random adam's here for chicken pie fish
pie
roast lunch yes good luck keep it up
please good to see you thanks for coming
guys good luck well done stacey
stace keep it up
charles jordan is it really true that
2000 women responded to your campaign
i don't believe that yes it's true but
it's actually over 2 000 you know that
but what shocked me more
is there 70 women that asked you out for
a date they didn't
yeah they were like did they want to do
that yeah they got no pride
you clearly think they don't 70 women
yeah it's very strange let me just
introduce you to some
put that in i don't know if i should do
this
hi giles my name is nikki i'm 28 years
old and a classical pianist
i'm looking for someone who's creative
with zest for life
if i could cook for you it'd be roasted
filleted beef
with porcini and loads of herbs wrapped
in parmesan
and we finished with a rich dark
chocolate cake with raspberry chili
fresh mint and only one spoon because
we'd be sharing
girls my name's sam i'm 38 i'm a
director of sales for hotel
mrs robinson and i'm looking for someone
spontaneous and who doesn't take
themselves too seriously who hopefully
shares my love of food
no they're not in public
hi charles my name's kit 57
i'm looking for someone articulate
intelligent and
sexy this isn't what i signed up for i
thought it was a classy food show
why would you cook for you it would
probably be my very special smoked fish
pie with a rich
creamy buttery sauce
there were only three of them there
weren't they weren't 70. can i see the
other 67 not that there was anything
because they were really lovely
now you've clearly been a big hit with
the women watching be sure your sperm
counts up to it
are you taking the piss well i wasn't
sure which is why i'm going to have it
tested
chefs have a genuine reason to having a
low sperm camera why are they where you
stand in the kitchen
you're very close to the stove and the
heat that's generated from the stove is
not good for the old testers my word it
cooks them so has you got a
low sperm can i will admit between you
and i yes i do have a low spent cow
he's got a low sperm count however they
have a lot of restaurants but he got no
spam
it's fired three times and worked for
this week i've been worrying about my
sperm count as everybody knows sperm
counts are down due to diets due to
environment you do all sorts of things
men are seeking fertility treatment more
often than women men are in all sorts of
trouble all over the western world
emasculated depressed
doomed what can we do about it as a food
person i want to know can i change the
way i eat
to improve my sperm count and give me a
better chance of creating future
generations
to find this out i'm going to go head to
head in a challenge for manliness
with gordon and gordon is a hamster
now according to recent statistics this
hamster on average is likely to have a
higher sperm count than me pound per
pound or more likely ounce per ounce or
fluid out for fluid ounce
what i want to find out is if i change
my diet radically and gordon is free to
change his
can i boost my sperm count and beat him
in a test
of virility i think giles has set
himself an enormous task
hamster's testicles are about a quarter
of their body size and
they produce far more sperm than the
average man these days
men have over the last 50 years men's
sperm count has dropped dramatically
so for my money i'm on the hamster right
so it's the moment of truth now it's the
fertility clinic
i'm going to make my deposit uh and then
this specialist is going to tell me what
lies in future for me
uh a sticky version of palm reading
basically
gosh i do hope i can deliver under all
this pressure
[Music]
am i doing it in the bog this is
terrible can i go in the ladies
the very least they're sort of freestyle
the whiff of perfume in the air
well i i don't really know what i was
worrying about there it's uh
the old magic is still there hi giles
i've got the results 8 out of 10 but
they could be 10 out of 10.
really yeah count 64 million so
that is really really good in terms of
um
motility very very good vitality
73 that's like an a 73
now the one area that
is okay but not brilliant which is
borderline is
morphology and what the morphology shows
is the shape and the structure of the
sperm
okay and yours is 14 which is borderline
which means it's on the lower side
borderline
that little hamster is not going to get
the better of me so next week i'm going
to be in the studio with zita finding
out what i can cook up to improve my
sperm count
you will die childless my friend i will
father
generations
that's more than i ever need to know
about giles coron's tadpoles
[Music]
next on the menu pudding's not looking
too promising
chris when his brown is cooked when it's
blankets
i almost make my favorite french frog
croak
it's awful it's disgusting and the
children have to face a harsh reality on
the farm
if the medicine doesn't work gary
is gonna have to be put down
[Applause]
welcome back to the f-word right stosie
four nights but
they were lovely yeah beautifully cooked
to be a great comment a brigade not only
do you have to be passionate we have to
be willing to work harder than most
people do in their entire lives you
understand what's going on yes
you got four in plus six then i want
five more in
i sent charles corin our resident
slacker to go and spend a day
in one of my restaurants to see if he
really does have a full day's work in
him
a working day for a commie here starts
at 8 a.m and ends at midnight
the starting salary is a magnificent 14
000 a year
right well i've got to the connaught i'm
going to meet angela hartnett and the
team and find out just what it takes to
be a chef in a gordon ramsay restaurant
and for me
a complete first i'm going into the
traders entrance
hello so how many are in today then phil
um full for lunch and we've got about
150 tonight right that goes like that
you're not gordon
i'm presuming as a restaurant critic you
know what this is i don't know it's like
a white radish or something
so well you say it's basically the
artichoke family salsafee you're
basically going to peel the whole lot
down in lemon water
yes all of this this is just one of
about 20 jobs you've got today
my doom in the shape of a shallot each
week
angela and her team chop 4 000 onions
they produce 15 gallons of soup and
serve a total of 2 000 meals
i feel joyous that giles is in the
kitchen and it's sort of a little
revenge on critics you know they'll
suddenly realize how hard it is and how
tough it is and
they can sit up there and go yeah it's
easy they haven't done this haven't done
that but actually come in the kitchen
and do it
you know do a full day's graft you know
with the pressures you have to do day to
day and then tell me
that we don't we know you know we're not
infallible we're not the pope for crying
out loud
your next job is our fish bones like i
said it's all the outbreaks
you're going to have to say these fish
these fish look the way that i feel
get rid of all the gills and take out
the gut
[Music]
the conaut serves 500 portions of fish a
week that's a thousand eyes some
terrible bloodthirsty sword has to gouge
out
this is just so just something i'm going
to eat in a restaurant again i'll be a
film critic
we basically put him on rolling
questions because if you can't manage
fish you should be able to manage that
at least
what does it mean to be working with
such a high profile chef everybody wants
to know what you're up to
whenever you meet your friends your
family they're talking about what's
going on then i'll learn as much as i
possibly can
in order to in the future do what to
have a nice little restaurant or
country house and like that in europe
i've been peeling onions now for what
feels like days
and i've got to tell you it's not the
hardest job i've ever had but
i'm losing the will to live
right let's go giles wait come on i've
got
no wandering thingy to get for lunch and
you're kissing around let's go you move
can you speed up a bit you're in service
now and you're basically in everyone's
way
to dark lamina venison yeah after that
we come back to 29 lambdas your cotton
and monkfish yeah
drain off the fat so basically go around
there get a shimwa drain it off
he's quite appalling yeah i think he
knows very slow you know he's not
methodical he doesn't work tidy so
you've got to be honest really you know
if you've done a trial today you
wouldn't have got a job
no i mean it's daylight fair point
gordon uh it's hard work
i smell of onions and fat like an old
hot dog i wouldn't do it again in a
thousand lifetimes it seems that the
world is full of ambitious young boys
and girls who think that working for you
is a privilege
but i am not one of them
[Music]
okay first of all i can't believe
you fell asleep in anger's kitchen never
seen that before in my life if a man
needs a kit a man needs a kip
in my life when i want to sleep when i'm
tired i go to sleep not in a kitchen
jars
well i didn't ask to go in that stupid
kitchen it was your idea you were trying
to prove a point that i couldn't hack it
i had a kit and i wanted to do a full
day's work that's all just get in there
and sweat and graft and understanding if
i wanted to give a full day's work
i'd get a proper job wouldn't i serious
enjoy it
i think i enjoyed it in a way i tried to
enjoy it i tried to whistle while i
worked an angel was going who's
whistling stop whistling i mean
what kind of a workplace is that it's
like a prison so stosien russell back
there okay
busting their nuts off yeah do you
understand exactly what they're going
through now i certainly do
if one of them would learn the principle
of heating up a plate it might have even
been one you're never happy are you
but i can make sure the plates are in
the oven yeah back in the kit now
back in your box right
right ladies and gentlemen yeah how are
we
good thank you yes yeah how was your
video really nice
yes not too rich uh no i've never had it
before and it was really thick
and what do you think the idea with the
chocolate sauce and the venison
didn't taste like venison did it taste
like game it was very
soft and subtle and it tasted very much
like beef but it was it was a lovely
blend of flavors it was strong enough
but not overpowering as you'd expect
game to be and it was
it was lovely everything worked really
really well and it was just done just
perfect melted in the mouth
loved it i've eaten venison before but
nothing that was ever to resemble this
and it's not just flattery because i'm
being interviewed here
it really is it was absolutely wonderful
beautifully i'd love to know how he done
[Applause]
it
now it's time for pudding each week on
the f word a guest tries to beat me
with their recipe for a pudding today
it's christopher parker with his rhubarb
crumble
if he beats me his dish will be served
to the f word diners
i think my rhubarb crumble will beat
gordon's because it's gonna be simple
it's gonna be a nice traditional recipe
that my nan's cooked for years my mum's
good fears i've cooked for years and i'm
really good at
and people like that people don't like
stuff too fancy we've got a bit of
custard on the top
great right christopher how are you very
well
yes good now what's the secret behind
the crumble you must have one ingredient
up your sleeve that's going to sort of
help taste it help make it taste better
demerara sugar to make it crunchy yes
caster sugar to make it sweet
chilled bowl yeah so that the bust
doesn't melt too much
okay very technical there with your
hands you look a little bit like gary
rose
orangutang this is a very
straightforward rhubarb crumble except
we're going to saute the rhubarb off in
some fresh vanilla finish a little bit
of butter
and then just slightly sprinkle it with
sugar so it makes a bit of a caramel
and what are you putting on top of your
uh crumble chris um i think i'm gonna go
for
an old favorite everyone likes um
custards what are you putting on i'm
just gonna serve it with some mascarpone
lemon mascarpone lemon mascarpone yes
just something a little bit sort of
i suppose not as rich as custard but
something a little bit lighter
i don't think my hand's gonna like yours
you know this crumble mix is actually
quite interesting because we've got some
hazelnuts in there some oats some flour
demerara sugar
and then just a very light sort of
lemon zest in there just to make it a
little bit more vibrant a little bit
sort of
easier to eat and one of the tricks of
my nan is to keep everything cold so
um keep your fingertips cold before you
knead the butter and also the bowl has
to be chilled
but then it can get moist so if you wipe
it with the tea towel then it's not
moist then
the butter doesn't kind of go into a
paste that you can still keep it into a
crumble
because sometimes if things are warm
then it gets a bit too soppy
this is a pickled ginger and this ginger
here is more associated with when you're
eating sushi
but it's actually quite sort of light in
pickle and
it's got rid of that sort of rawness and
it's not so sweet
um chris yeah it's burning
oh um yeah can we get some more rhubarb
please
and chris something we always remember
in a kitchen yeah when it's brown it's
cooked when it's blacked
our hubs are like industrial hubs
they're too hot now it's the hob now
yeah nothing to do with nana nothing to
do with your lack of concentration now
it's the whole
it's your fault you keep talking what
was the food like
um in eastenders in that cafe that was
awful was it really it was awful yeah
who was the chef well uh the props guys
used to cook the foods
oh really um and to all that credit they
were quite good but obviously
if they cooked it like half an hour
before it could be cold yeah
i'm just gonna put the final topping on
top of the rhubarb and it's actually
quite interesting because the oats
absorb more of the juice than it would
be if it was just sort of flour and
butter
and the butter gets it really nice and
crispy and the oats just start to absorb
all that flavor from rhubarb
how long for nana's recipe um maybe
about
10 minutes at the most 10 minutes okay
did you take this long learning your
lines
no no
look at that nice homemade
normal rhubarb crumble bring it over i
always like to compare them just before
they go
okay well let's put them together a bit
of a chef's thing yours looks like bird
seed
okay or cat litter cutlet thank you
mine looks nice you know old-fashioned
you know that you haven't tasted it
yet yeah you're slagging it off chris i
know but i think mine's going to taste
better anyway because she's got all odd
ingredients in it
right ready yeah here we go boy good
luck by the way can i have the um top
shelf
you can have whatever shelf you wish i'd
like to wish you the best it's just luck
thing and yours looks awful
how are the turkeys doing it's been a
bloody tough week you know that
is it poor fellows they're not well gary
not well
that abscess has grown it's not as easy
to live the good life as i thought
we're fattening up six turkeys for
christmas dinner but one of them
gary has got an abscess on his foot
peter the vet
has been giving him antibiotics
okay now we've got to get this down his
throat
the syringe has to go right down the
back of his throat
there and give it a squeeze
okay close his mouth and let him swallow
as he swallowed you see him swallow oh
wow good boy
i can't believe my daughter's kissing
gary joking aside
it's time for the kids to face a harsh
reality if the medicine doesn't work
gary is gonna have to be put down
[Music]
while the children wait for news of gary
they've been helping me in the garden
i'm growing fresh seasonal vegetables to
go on the plate with the turkey
i'm determined my kids will grow up know
where their food comes from
unlike one in three kids who don't even
know what chips are made of
what's that
[Applause]
black cabbage no in italian italian no
cavanero right let's start again then
let's start again what's this one
beetroot what's that one
[Applause]
but the mrs isn't as happy with the farm
it's wet it's muddy
the turkeys have begun to smell a bit
even though they're regularly cleaned
out and
the kids just get caked in everything
and it's not great um
they're [ __ ] everywhere um garden's
an absolute mess
i have to say i think the honeymoon
period is over it stinks how can i get
rid of that smell
probably what would be a good idea to
try is if we spread straw on this area
for now and keep it dry
yeah um it'll enable the birds to walk
about on dry ground
and what about put them in the garden
and let them spread their wings a bit i
think it's
much better that these birds are allowed
out and give them some freedom left
to walk around don't tell mummy okay
please
oh no i told you so what's the ladies on
bird flu
there are no directors from death row
the people who organize all of this
um at the moment because we don't have
bird flu here so free-range birds are
quite
uh quite happy to be out there's no
problem there so you're more than
confident that we'll still have
free-range turkeys
on the table on the 25th of december yes
absolutely there'll be three ranged
birds
in the supermarkets for christmas unless
the situation gets any worse
that's good news absolutely right come
here we're gonna dry their
pens out we're gonna scatter the pen
okay
with some straw we get all the straw
like this yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
megan
no no more no more i think they look
happy don't you
yeah so no more
yeah we shouldn't throw hay around
everywhere come here
i didn't throw it dropped on you
right listen just tell mommy okay she
slipped over it don't tell him
what really happened no no listen listen
listen some sweeties
yeah yeah gary definitely seems to be
more comfortable on the straw
and he's been on antibiotics for a week
so it's time for peter to make a
decision
about whether he's going to pull through
or will he have to be put down
hi everyone what do you say is peter
sorry
um right he's been on the painkillers
he's had antibiotics he's clearly not
eating
and it's peter's decision
unfortunately whether or not gary stays
with us jack
till christmas or we're gonna have to
put him down
so peter what do you think well i've had
a look at him today
walking around but i just want to have a
look at his foot one more time
if you remember the base of his foot was
quite swollen yes
and and that's the important thing oh
look and that's
softened now it's not as swollen at all
this joint is working quite well and um
when i was watching walking earlier he
was walking really well
so the good news is i think he's made it
and i think we'll take him off the
antibiotics
and hopefully we're there okay happy yes
all right gary's staying with us
gary's gonna be with for christmas you
got a turkey for christmas yes
i have a little taste of mine yeah and i
have a little taste of yours
because i'm dying to taste it but you
know what i'm gonna taste it without the
custard uh christopher
it's not bad okay two out of ten good
luck good luck my man yeah yes
it's time for our rhubarb crumbles to be
judged and it's my reputation on the
line
so far it's one winter the guest cook
get out and one win to me mum i've never
one had you not taught me properly know
that
but i should win hands down to this
young upstart we've chosen our judges
from tonight's diners
and all that matters is taste wow
when i put cinnamon in there though like
that that's good
i don't know why i think i can taste
lemon juice but really maybe
maybe it's not maybe it's just the
combination but it's not quite tart
enough
this is your additional metal
this is totally the reverse it's not
quite as sweet either
it's got a nice little touch to it it's
got to be dessert number two number two
dessert two
so i have to say the winner is this week
yes
well done gordon yes
what congratulations yes well done i did
never stay seated
no don't be disappointed three my nan's
not gonna be happy
i'm gutted um i didn't like his rhubarb
crumble i don't
it was all right but it doesn't taste
like rhubarb crumble mine tasted like
good old-fashioned rebel crumble i think
those blind tasters
i don't think they were tasting it i
think they got mixed up somehow but
what's even worse is that all three of
them chose gordon's and then choose not
even one of them like mine
next on the menu it's a treat from
scotland
it's like something i have an alien film
and we find out which comedy will be
back
and which one will be going home for
good so the person i'd like to keep in
the brigade of the f-word
[Applause]
time to find out what our guests thought
of their pudding
delicious very nice um fruity flavors
nutty top bit it was bitter
it was gritty nutty i don't like that
perfect instead three-course more
delicious
now um you're a bit of a food
connoisseur right i pretend to be yeah
don't tell anyone you sort of almost
tasted everything on the planet
within reason well i actually think i'm
beating you now no
yeah i've tasted something you haven't
tasted can only be
a vegetarian lasagna not quite better
than that
gannett we're in a very remote and
inaudible part of the british house
right in the very northwest tip of
scotland just above the outer hemis in
search
of something unique a delicacy called
janet
a sea bird that's notoriously greedy the
gannet is actually a protected species
the islanders of lewis are the only
people in the uk who are allowed to kill
and eat these birds
but they're under pressure from the
animal rights lobby and it's probably my
last chance
to taste this bird
a little delicacy what do they taste
like oh
amber nectar salty duck
fishy duck fishy salty duck fishy salty
duck
this is the rarest bird ever and i
haven't tasted one and i've been cooking
for 20 years and i'm dying to get hold
of this thing
there's gonna be somewhere i can get a
hold of one well you're probably gonna
have to try sweeney
[Music]
hi jordan yes hi i'm sweeney sweeney i
understand you're looking for some
cuckoo
it's illegal to buy or sell gannit or
googa as it's known locally
but sweeney was born in lewis and he has
offered me one of his birds from this
year's cul
having eaten nearly everything there is
to eat
in this world i've never ever had the
chance to come across this delicacy well
i'll say
it you know it'll be an experience the
islanders salt cure the gannet which
only adds to its overpowering smell
so sweeney keeps his in the garage not a
good sign for something i'm about to eat
god the smell what have you done to it i
just told us
jesus christ almighty
it's like something i have an alien film
oh
god look at the fat on here yep
and that's been in there for how long uh
less than two weeks
really what's in that liquid just salt
so it's almost like a brine right and
this is the delicacy
that i've traveled hundreds of miles
right across sea and land
to look at this what's your whale isn't
it
oh god say sweeney's no cook
so he sends me off to find someone whose
traditional gannet recipe has been
handed down for generations
that's for you for me because apparently
you know exactly what to do
so you're going to quarter it first yes
it doesn't look very appetizing
traditionally this was cooked as well
but i
i take this fork the face
one two three
four there we go and that's it you boil
it for an hour and twenty minutes to
around an hour and a half
no soul no pepper no salt no cover no
nothing
just cute another sneak a bay leaf in
there or something
not a hole no the thought of somebody
doing something like putting a wine
sauce or something like that i don't
think oh my god you know
the cooking smell is rank patty hell
[Music]
that's worse than rotten eggs then no
it's not at all
how long has that lingered for that i
mean tomorrow anyway
let's see if this thing's cooked there
we are tattoos
wow it doesn't smell as strong now as it
did when it first started cooking i told
you
fascinating having seen how it's cooked
i'm dreading eating it
that's incredible it's so fishy
mean it's absolutely incredible there's
a cross between a sort of survivor
tuna stroke mackerel and veganism
and with a meaty flavor
god it's quite refreshing i didn't think
it would be that tasty now that
he told you so here you go the meat is
delicious i'm not that keen on the fat
no it's quite the farting required yeah
that's quite
sort of i'd much prefer rendering down
and using it for
heating my stove
i've asked marianne to come to london to
share her recipe with the f-word diners
let's take it to our food critics see
what he's got to say yes here we go
now this is a rare delicacy
yeah have
have a wee bite of something historical
no don't move away like that taste it
come on
it smells of pickled uh pickled fish
taste a bit of this one here no no no no
no because that's that's a joke
it's not a joke but god's sake man stop
being paranoid
skin of the gannet god almighty
it can't be worse than a raw kebab for
god's sake that is a delicacy
that's like sucking the puss out of a
boil come
on i'm so sorry about my friend he's so
rude i'm
you're very cool and swamped and
sophisticated
get your mouth around some ganache man
yeah get some diesel just a wee bit
a bird inside you and i bit this one as
well
they've got to eat together you see this
whole thing is about being suave
mine isn't so he could be in trouble
yeah it's called brill cream come on
did you take that out hmm
the inside of intestines in your but yet
taste of poo
whereas this doesn't taste quite that
nice
you